to our viewers watching on pbs in the
united states and to all of you around
the world welcome we begin the day
entering the fifth month of the russian
invasion of ukraine and
what seems most certain tonight there
will be many more months until an end to
the war becomes plausible and possible
the planning and the decisions made this
week by western countries could all have
long time horizons g7 countries have
agreed to place price caps on russian
oil sold abroad now the plan is untested
but if it works it could deal the final
blow to vladimir putin's ability to
finance the war in ukraine
the changes at nato could also be in
terms of years not months nato
announcing plans to increase its rapid
response forces from forty thousand to
three hundred thousand and that will
include a sizable increase in the number
of u.s soldiers stationed along nato's
eastern flank where the alliance in
russia meet head on
we'll discuss the pros and cons the
risks and promises of all of this in
just a moment but first this report that
begins at the end of the g7 summit in
bavaria unity among close allies that is
the symbolic message the g7 aimed to
send to the world despite a litany of
problems facing the planet the
atmosphere at the final session on
tuesday seemed relaxed
on monday ukraine's president joined by
video link russia's war dominated the
talks the world's seven largest
economies of the eu determined to
support ukraine for as long as it takes
but the summit also looked forward to
the time after the war especially
the most important thing is that we want
to get together from the perspective of
the g7 but also with others including
the european union to discuss the
question of reconstruction
we need a marshall plan for ukraine and
it needs to be well planned and
developed that is what we've set out to
do
across the globe countries are feeling
the knock-on effects of the war so it
was good that leaders from the global
south joined the summit nations like
india indonesia and senegal
among their concerns the fight against
hunger to address that the g7 and the eu
have established a global alliance for
food security pledging over four billion
euros this year to help those facing the
worst shortages
another major focus of this summit the
battle to protect the climate schultz
put forward a plan for a climate club
open to all nations willing to commit to
the goal of limiting temperature rises
to 1.5 degrees and becoming emissions
neutral by mid-century
we all agree what the future holds which
is not gas this is particularly true for
germany we want our economy to be co2
neutral in 2045 and that has
consequences for the question of the use
of fossil resources whether it's coal
oil or gas gas
but climate activists some of whom
protested near the summit venue say
extending use of fossil fuels even for a
short time is the wrong response to
energy shortages
we are angry that leaders at the end
commit to long-term targets
but not commit to the immediate measures
needed
to give a clear frame to the industry to
phase out fossil fuels and to enter into
renewable energy in a much more rapid
way
those arguments will continue but for
now schultz said the g7 has demonstrated
what democratic alliances can achieve
from the bavarian mountains the world's
richest countries standing in solidarity
against a backdrop of uncertainty